come in number 169 your time is up
[Applause]
[Music]
yes it is time once again for me to get
self-indulgent and just ramble on for a
while a lot something that I really
enjoy and this time up I'm gonna talk
Red Dwarf
no particular impetus for this I don't
think they've got new stuff coming out
right now I'm actually a couple of
series behind on this show I just I
haven't found the time and it's not
something that's easy for me to get a
hold of without having to shell out to
actually buy it which you know I don't I
don't like to blind buy anymore
even stuff that I like and expect to be
good so I am a little bit behind but
I've loved the show for a very long time
now on the off chance that anyone
watching this doesn't know what red
dwarf is red dwarf is a British science
fiction comedy show and it's been around
since the 80s and if your first thought
is oh wow must be like thirty series
worth of this thing nah not so much
because as is not excessively uncommon
with British television they do a series
every now and then when they feel like
it
you know when they can wrangle the cast
when the writers have enough ideas and
then so forth so they don't do one every
year and there have been long hiatuses
between them especially lately so that
there's that but I just I love this show
so much the way I found this show um and
I like I don't know I I imagine most
folks in my circle who will be
subscribed to me have heard of this show
because you know the internet spreads
word around but I found out about the
show way before like the inner I mean
the internet existed but it wasn't much
of a thing yet so I thought about it out
about this show in middle school I had a
friend I don't know how he got ahold of
it but he lent me a VHS that had a
couple of episodes from the first series
of this show and I immediately loved it
primarily for the character dynamics but
I liked the setting and the premise as
well since I'm gonna gush most about the
characters we'll set those aside let's
talk about that
in premise setting and premise is in the
at some point in the future a number of
years from now doesn't actually matter
on a deep space ship called the Red
Dwarf there is the literal lowest ranked
member of the crew by the name of Dave
Lister and he is just there to get a
paycheck he does not care about this job
you know he's surrounded by people who
are you know trying to work their way up
the ladder you know lifetime commitment
to this sort of he doesn't care he's
just there because it's a way for him to
make a bit of money so he can do
something he'd actually like to do he's
a bit of a layabout he's a bit of a slob
especially early on and what ends up
happening is he smells aboard a pet a
cat specifically that didn't go through
quarantine so that gets him in a lot of
trouble and when he refuses to hand that
cat over to the captain so that he can
dissect it and make sure it didn't have
a disease he his punishment is to be put
in stasis for the remainder of the
journey which you know just freezes him
in time and that the reason that that's
a punishment is that means he's not
gonna be a drain on resources and also
that he's forfeiting the remainder of
his pay for the rest of that trip so he
goes in thing he's got to come out in
six months and instead he comes out
three million years later because what
happened in the interim was there was a
massive radiation leak and it wiped out
all the rest of the crew and the
computer could not let him out until the
background had reached is until the
radiation have reached a safe background
level and so three million years later
he is alone on this ship except not
quite there's the computer which I
mentioned before known as Holly which is
very intelligent but also going senile
so not as reliable as it should be for
how smart it is and I'm saying it at
this point because depending on what
series of the show you want it's either
him or her I'll get into that a little
bit later and then there's the capped
and when I say the cat I don't mean the
cat that Lister smuggled on but a
descendant of that cat because that cat
by coincidence of where she was when the
hum
when the ship got the radiation dose she
was and she was pregnant when when
Lister got her that's the first thing
and she was locked off in a place where
she was safe from the radiation and
species evolved to the cat and the cat
is you know he looks like a person with
some fangs but his behavior that's a cat
so there's him he's around but much like
a pet cat you would have now he doesn't
I mean he likes Lister all right he just
doesn't really care you super
self-absorbed and all about his own
thing but additionally Lister also has
the company of a hologram of his old
bunk mate
Arnold Rimmer and Lister hates Rimmer
Rimmer hates him too but the reason that
he's around is Holly is projecting his
stored personality as a hologram so that
Lister has some proper company and he
doesn't go crazy now as the show goes on
other characters get brought in by
season 3 we have Kryten who's an Android
who gets brought into things later on we
get additional characters like Kochanski
and some other occasional off-again
on-again appearances from some a lot of
one-off characters as well but that's
your basic starting setup and like I
said from series to series it varies a
lot so like the first two series of this
is very sort of locked location sitcom
it's very much about how you know listen
remember don't get along and it's the
conflict of them trying to deal with
each other and it's very confined to the
to the corridors and a couple of bunk
beds in the Red Dwarf itself once we
start getting to season 3 it expanded in
scope quite a bit they got a bigger
budget Crichton joined the team so it
was a larger cast and they also started
going off the ship more they started
travelling we started exploring more the
show started to deal in bigger sci-fi
ideas in a very comedic way but you know
it got more ambitious notably so and it
would do some odd tangents as it went
down the line now one of the first
things you should know
Red Dwarf if a reason that you like
sci-fi in general is because you like
knowing how things work and everything
is logical it makes sense this is not
the show for you because this show
amongst other things has little to no
interesting continuity if it contradicts
something that was established as
continuity previously it doesn't even
bother to retcon it or address it it's
just like no it's this now a guy like a
good example the closest they ever came
like the one time they tried to quote
ago to address a major shift in
continuity was at the start of series 3
so the end of series 2 ends on I don't
want to call it a cliffhanger but I big
set up for a massive status quo shake-up
and what it leaves and what it sets up
that is about to happen it's gonna have
massive implications something you can't
skip over and you can't not deal with
except the show skips over and doesn't
deal with it and then adds a character
onto the crew who hadn't been a regular
part of the cast before now both the
resolution of the plotline leftover from
series 2 and the addition of the new
character are covered in a Star Wars
style text crawl at the start of the
first episode of series 3
but that text crawl go intentionally
goes so fast you can't actually read it
and this was the show's way of saying we
don't we're not doing this because we
don't care we're gonna jump to the point
at which we can do stuff we want to do
and that's basically the entire approach
of the show they don't they the show and
its creators and it's writers and it's
cast even I've never felt the obligation
to tie up and revisit and pay off stuff
that they did earlier if they lose
interest in it and decide they want to
do something that doesn't what that
can't logically be the next step based
on where they were like oh we don't care
we're just gonna jump to this cuz that's
what we want to do and that's the show
is based around what ideas can we work
with what jokes can we tell and the
jokes get I don't want to say they get
thinner on the ground but the show
overall gets a little bit more
melancholy in its later series as it
sort of embraces the loneliness of
listers situation a little bit more um
but it does deal in some interesting
sci-fi concept as it goes along with
some of the things that they encounter
with some time-travel stuff with some
physics weirdness and and things like
that it does it does tackle interesting
ideas and also we can do character drama
well at times also why like one of my
favorite episodes is series 3 marooned
which is just Rimmer and Lister crashed
on a planet and it's just the two of
them stuck for a while and at this great
episode so it can go for a large scope
it can go for tiny and intimate it
always remembers to be funny at least to
some degree even and it's more
melancholy episodes the jokes are still
there so it's it's really wonderful but
what makes this show awesome is
ultimately the characters I love this
cast of characters I'll sort of start
with who for me is my least favorite but
he's still good and that's Crichton the
Android now as I said he's a slightly
later Edition he comes in in series 3
but he's been around so long at this
point that he's generally considered one
of the regulars so with with Crichton I
think it's just for me I've seen Android
tropes played out in too many other
places I think ultimately that's it
Crichton is a good character and a good
comedic Android but he's probably the
least unique in terms of
characterization for this kind of
character in this kind of setting he is
still well played he's still interesting
he's still funny but he is the most sort
of oh we would expect that in a sci-fi
comedy show sort of character there's
the cat who I mentioned the cat is
awesome because they oh man so the cat
he is just so
self-obsessed and he's always on and it
and he's doing it practically for
himself like he'll just smoothly glide
into a room look around and he just sees
listen goes oh it's just you what a
waste of a good move or he'll tell them
hey be careful cuz if we pass any
mirrors I'm there for the day and I love
his self-obsession and like I said he
does care about the other characters a
little but about as much as a real-life
pet cat movie and that's not a knock on
cats I do blight cats but I mean let's
be honest they kind of don't give a crap
about people most of the time and that
is true for this guy he's interested in
him you know how can he how can he relax
how can you look good how can he eat
what can he attempt to woo
so that he's great me never gets old
then there's um there's Holly the
computer now I mentioned it's either a
he or she depending on when you come in
so first two series it was a guy and
then they went for a stretch as being a
woman and then Holly wasn't there and
then Holly came back as a guy I don't
know if they went back to a woman again
in later series as I said I actually I'm
a couple series behind at this point but
I my preference is slightly for the male
version of Holly not because it's a
better performance there's just a slight
difference in characterization in that I
feel like male Holly you get a sense
that I mean Holly is not particularly
stable and not particularly helpful in
any case but you get the sense with male
Holly you you get that feeling that you
used to have it together but you kind of
don't now you know you you get a little
bit of that vibe of somebody who used to
be intelligent and it's been degrading
over time whereas female Holly's a bit
more just spaced out like she does you
don't get as much of a vibe of you used
to have it together it's a bit more of a
boy you were always like this weren't
you
and again that's it just a general vibe
but neither is better or worse I just
it's a personal preference but both of
them are very good both of them are very
funny especially considering that all
they get to be is a face on a screen and
just delivering lines now and then which
you know is it sounds like an easy job
but you get so little interaction with
the cast doing that but they both do it
quite well I'm not gonna get into some
of the other characters who show up late
or like to chance key cuz like it did
fans ever really mix melee I'm on her
I'm fine with her but you know that's
just how it is my favorite character
though by far not even close
Rimmer I love Rimmer so much and part of
the reason I love Rimmer's Rimmer as a
kind of character that should be
insufferable he shouldn't work and I
actually didn't realize this until I saw
the pilot for the failed American
version of Red Dwarf I say fail they you
know they didn't get past the pilot they
can get picked up to series but I
remember watching that and I could not
stand that Rimmer
because the the Rimmer and the American
version actually had pretty much almost
all of the qualities that
original flavor Rimmer did but he was
missing one key component because Rimmer
the reason he should be annoying is he
is completely self-serving he has a
sense of superiority about himself yet
at the same time he is more than happy
to cut corners if it's to his own
benefit he's always throwing people
under the bus never takes responsibility
for himself he's pedantic he's obsessed
with regulations even though he can't
remember what they are half the time but
again remembers them when they are to
his personal advantage and you know he's
just obsessed with climbing the ladder
even after like the rest of the crew is
dead there's no ladder left to climb
he's still obsessed with that and all of
this should make for an insufferable
character but here's the key component
that Rimmer has that the American
version failed to get he hates himself
but you really deep down he hates
himself and that element of
self-loathing gives him just enough of a
sympathetic edge and that sense that you
can't you actually you now have that in
common with Rimmer is like I don't like
you but you don't like you either okay
well we've got that at least whereas the
American version didn't have that sense
of inward directed hatred and sense of
being unsuccessful so you in the
American version you had you know the
the blaming everyone else for his for
his failure to move forward but it
didn't feel motivated by anything other
than not then you know wanting to blame
someone else whereas original Rimmer he
it's very clearly motivated by he
doesn't he never wants to face the fact
that he is in the situation he's in
because of himself but deep down he also
knows that's the case and that is what
makes him awesome and not to mention
he's got a fantastic I mean all the
characters everyone has great chemistry
with everybody that's another one of the
things about this show I get the OEE I
get the feeling that depending on which
fans you ask different fans will tell
you which series are the best you get
wildly different answers depending on
what people like but I think what even
in the series that I don't like as much
as others what always pulls it forward
is these people are
so well together and you feel like they
are having fun and so you get to have
fun with them that's honestly something
that can paper over a lot of sins in any
medium if you're watching people enjoy
themselves honestly I think that's the
entire basis for why we even had the
Ocean's eleven series of films
honestly the original Ocean's eleven
structurally narrative Lee is fine it's
not remarkable but what's infectious
about it it's how much fun all these
people seem to be happening and that
sort of vibe is very much present here
in Red Dwarf for pretty much the whole
run of it oddly enough even in the first
series when the actors who play Rimmer
and Lister did not actually get along
very well but it fed into the dynamic
between those characters especially in
those early years so it did work fine
but it was really it's really fantastic
and it's these characters that make me
want to come back the settings the ideas
that cause the concepts sometimes they
work sometimes they don't sometimes they
are honestly really cool ideas and
really well executed but other times
it's like that was fine but man that
line that zinger that look that
character gave the other one that's why
I'm here and that's why I keep coming
back and there's there's it's just a
wonderful mix of people and perspectives
and characters constantly butting heads
yet also not having the option to not
put up with each other they have to
because they are all they have there's
nowhere else for them to turn so they
got to make this work as much as
inherently they can't ever make it work
like as a team and as a functioning
group but it's so it is wonderful it is
funny it is biting it's touching at
times it is dark at times but it is
always worth coming back to see these
characters they're they're great
characters in and of themselves but
especially to see them bounce off each
other and to see the interplay and
ultimately I will always come back to
Lister and Rimmer and their dynamic and
Rimmer especially as being the heart of
what I cannot get enough of but that's
why I love Red Dwarf have you seen it
why do you love it or why don't you love
it or what series do you love and want
most didn't work for you because like I
said I've never really affirmed
sense if there's any kind of consensus
among the fandom as to what ones are the
quote-unquote good series and which ones
aren't but I'd be curious to hear from
you folks so whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
Oh bunch of stuff you can do because
there's buttons and there's links
including once my patreon if you feel
like supporting me that way if you don't
doe sweat it there's other links to look
at as well but you know what if you
don't want to click on any of them
that's no skin off my back because at
the end of the day you folks are the
council and I just run the meetings so
until next time this council is
adjourned
yes maggots
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]